zu dritt ist okay würfel 5 die lamelle
ist keine ahnung
servus es kommt zu einem ganz besonderen
video ich habe mir für heute eine ganz
spezielle challenge aus gedacht ich hab
mich da ein bisschen inspirieren lassen
von einer folge geht er online von denon
kev dies unten verlinkt und zwar von
sieht das heute folgendermaßen jedes mal
wenn ich einen film mache würfel wir mit
einer verve lab licht auf meinem handy
als allererstes werden wir würfeln um zu
sehen wie viel würfel aktiv sind und
jetzt mal wenn ich ein killer kriege ich
den einmal den maximen der anteil genau
diesen übergezogen
die durchfahrt reinheit und wir dürfen
jetzt erst mal wie viele
zwei würfel alter was junge das so
l'aquila jetzt leute ist es nicht so
wenn ich jetzt ein killer dann würfelt
max mit der app und wenn die app jetzt
sagen wir mal 26 ausgibt dann kriege ich
für zwölf sekunden den helm aufgezogen
muss für zwölf sekunden mit herr im
spiel glück für dich liebe lebt und
liebt es überlebt alter schwede hier
hole ich mir aber ich glaube das ist
quatsch ihr dass ich den kopfhörern habe
ich will aber nicht defensive stetig die
voll drauf wir normal spielt und der
blogger nicht mehr viele leben das
locker leichter der erste kill bahnt
sich an
könnt ihr noch zwei frische leute ich
weiß nicht oder nicht doch eher kopf
riss ist es immer noch derselbe ja und
jetzt aber er ist okay jetzt wird die
würfel würfel inc ok 1 all das werde ich
heute spürbar spiel minecraft mit einem
head mit dem helm sage ich mit einem
eimer auf alter hat mit nur einmal okay
nächster gegner habe ich fest mit dem
falschen feld geschlagen kann es sein
dass täglich gedacht sehr wichtig alles
klar wo ist der nächste gegner wir gehen
auch mal wieder darüber gerade noch ein
bisschen glück gehabt weil es kann auch
durchaus turbulent werden heute wenn ich
nämlich mankell mache und da sind
irgendwie zwei gegner es aber auch
einmal mehr zu organisieren so von mir
zeigen gleichzeitig drüber und dann gar
nicht was man dafür alles klar
wo ist der nächste gegner gehen
die wirbel machen in biel gehen teile
der als ehemaliger
die reise habe ich in die vollen
rüstung am start haha okay weil lege ich
wert weil komplett alle hat natürlich
das nicht mehr so ist er hier ist hier
ist er ein gegner vor dem das management
ist als gott
das wird knackig das für richtig knackt
alter hier war noch nie
nein die wahl überhaupt niemand und die
runde war voll die war voller erfolg wir
können house track to a aaa aaa aaa
nicht problem erkannt problem nicht
weiter auf mich draufgehen ich glaub ich
glaubte drauf ich weiß es nicht
wir können holen
gleichwie schicken
das album kommt
wer heute zu vielen weißt du wenn du von
mir kommt so hofft die mehr oder weniger
degas 22 dankeschön von mehr oder
weniger originellen fall kommt von mir
die leute jetzt taktisch überlegen okay
okay geht auf mich nicht so gut aus
münchen ein zweieinhalb herzen 22
okay okay aber es bringt mir nichts wenn
ich tot bin
aber es laufe zwar ein dicker alter
schwerer junge nicht nach dem treffen
keine ahnung keine ahnung müsse nicht
richtig gas geben es direkt hinter uns
und da kommt der andere sollte ich ein
verbrennt verbrennt
wir kommen nicht raus ja westermann
natur aufgehen würde erstmal die egal
was für eine turbulente runde alter aber
dass bisher erst einmal neben getragen
jetzt muss ich weiter ändern
finde ich an hängt vielleicht
ich glaube nicht 2010 ein zwingendes hat
die vorlage rüstungs punkte keine voller
rüstung und feuer auf die vier direkt ja
auch was für ein krasses glück wir haben
nokia setzt zwei leute in kuba den
können sie uns nicht ob sie uns auf gar
keinen fall
nein nein wir viele vorwürfe sind cdu 34
6 7 8 9 10 uhr heute schwer etwas zu
bekommen
das war genau das was nicht passieren
darf es mit mit helmen uns damit weiter
neue us-team gelegt
ok es aber es nicht ergeben sich ins
wasser gefallen
ich hab ich noch nicht ich hab ich nicht
ich glaube ich erst übernahm ohne okay
der patch für leute sind dann das noch
einer
ja ja ich weiß nicht boxen sich vor gott
das death metal jetzt richtig knackig
alter direkt bereich einmal bereit
ich musste gleich mal den jahren
überlegen ich komme auf den gehen was
sich da vielleicht keine 1356 alter
schwerverletzter 37 gegen die wand die
kommen einfach klasse ihr ding machen
alter schwede was war das denn der vier
teile de
es gibt vielleicht ein echtes
menschenkind nein nein nein nein
shutterstock anfangen anfangs gar nicht
zu entscheiden dass man egal was das für
eine runde leistung
und nicht auf mich macht es nicht nur
ich mach das war das dritte doch die
brust für die branche nippel sitzen
braking bag weiter
wichtig wird jetzt länger durch einen dr
aber ich bin dafür bezahlt tag liest du
solltest es als marco oder sowas lese
menschen etwas details also der betagte
mann damit zu dritt ist okay robert
bobbe 5
wie kommen ist keine ahnung 86 12 36 89
was ist das für eine runde alter jäger
die eimer runden ich hab's wirklich ins
deathmatch
nicht nur dass ich meine wir haben es
auch noch einmal versucht
problem aber ich glaube dass machen
machen wir gar nicht so viel aus er
denkt drei herzen leid ich keine manga
ich kannte ich auch selbst apps werden
ist ich konnte ich weiß nicht darum ist
keine absätze fall an
schön schön dass wir jetzt der krönende
abschluss geworden für diese hätten wir
das gewonnen aber es war ein schöner
fall leute lassen daumen nach oben da
bringt das gefallen hat und wenn ihr
vorschläge habt die so in diese richtung
gehen wieder handicap games mäßig dann
schreibt mir die gerne unten in den
kommentaren ich verspreche ich lese
jeden vorschlag den check max ab der ist
auch verlinkt ich bin macht macht und
wir sehen das nächste video wieder haut
rein macht's gut und